can you subscribe as you know please we
spoke earlier about how at the lower
non-confidential levels of scientology's
bridge Howard is saying that what's
wrong with you is your reactive mind yes
okay
well in Scientology once you've gotten
rid of your reactive mind that is what's
called the state of clear okay so after
you finish state of clear the next thing
on the bridge is the OT levels well if
you've already gotten rid of your active
mind what the heck are you supposed to
do now well now L Ron Hubbard says Okay
first what was wrong with you was just
your reactive mind but now the next
thing you have to resolve the next thing
that's wrong with you is you actually
have tens of thousands of of thetans
stuck to your body and they all have
their own reactive Minds you have to
audit the thetans
how do you order the things are these
like different
shades of your inner mind and you just
have to try to access them somehow you
use the e-meter just like we spoke about
except now you've got a divider that
separates the cans so they don't short
circuit and you hold both cans in one
hand and you have the emitter in front
of you so now you're auditing yourself
you're telepathically talking to the
things that are stuck to you
your thinking the commands instead of
saying them out loud
and you sort of do drills where you
practice looking for emitter reads at
the instant you have a thought
you're telepathically
auditing spirits that L Ron Hubbard says
are stuck to your body does this sound
like a recipe for a mental breakdown or
a heck of a mental Journey
wherever that leads it's a good lead
anywhere it probably lead to a very bad
place right very often does
and you combine that with the fact that
Scientology is against any forms of
mental help or health outside of
Scientology and you have a recipe for
disaster now you might go where did all
these spirits come from that are stuck
to your body this is where Xenu comes
into play so Hubbard says that 75
million years ago Xenu was basically a
dictator at uh the galactic
Confederation is like 70 something or 80
something planets somewhere in the Milky
Way and uh Xenu was like a dictator an
Overlord for either one of these planets
or the whole system
and they had a population problem and
Xenu was like we need to get rid of like
half the people
so we called them all in for tax audits
Alvin Hubbard didn't like the IRS so of
course the story has to do with tax
audits okay called them all in for tax
audits said psych froze them in
glycol loaded them up on Space planes
flew them to Earth remember the story
has to be Earth because the story is
what's wrong with us
flew them to Earth dropped them in
volcanoes blew them up with hydrogen
bombs
and then captured them with like Spirit
magnets I'm making up words because okay
um and these disembodied spirits of
these people that got blown up have just
been blown in the wind here on Earth and
they attach themselves to things and
they can be in the environment and they
stick to bodies and everything and so
and they all have reactive Minds so at
scientology's upper levels if you get
sick or you have cancer or there's
something wrong with you Scientology
will say
that's one of your body things you need
to get some auditing to fix the body
thing so this story
uh you do it with a kind of bit of a
chuckle but when done seriously so it's
just told in a serious way
like to like or written down you read it
by most accounts scientologists struggle
when they read this for the first time
because this is not consistent with what
scientologists are hoping for us on the
OT levels they're hoping for some real
life-changing magic the way these things
are described and sold they're
remember they're hoping that these OT
levels are going to make them give them
the ability to go like completely
independent of their body at will yeah
exteriorize from your body go back into
your body you know like I have some real
Spirit Powers the first is kind of a
shock this is but then you still
probably believe you hope yeah and you
might be you might turn into on yourself
self-critical that this is I'm just not
strong enough yet
yeah because also part of the
Scientology remember it works 100 of the
time when used 100 correctly and if it
doesn't
it could be because something's not
being done right but it also could be
because
you're you're doing bad things that
you're not telling people about like if
you're committing present time over its
crimes sins
scientologists will be like that's part
of the reason auditing isn't working on
you is because you're committing
criminal behavior that you're not being
honest about so every Scientologist is
sort of incentivized to to make auditing
work on them okay now Lex this work is a
little crazy on ot3 you learn about the
OT the body things for the first time
when you finish ot3 you attest to having
achieved the state of having no more
body things and then you start o24
and he's like psych you got more you got
more BTS except those other BTS they had
drug problems and that's why you
couldn't find them the first time so
we're gonna do a little something a
little different here do something a
little different there got to get rid of
these BTS that were addicted to drugs
okay then you finish ot4 and you're
thinking man I hope we got the good
stuff soon and then you get to ot5 and
he's like psych you got more BTS you
couldn't find these BTS because they
were all bunched up together in clusters
and first you have to break up the
Clusters and then you can get rid of the
BTS and you're like okay gotta do that
and this was all El Ron Hubbard approved
yeah this is from L Ron Hubbard and then
after you finish over T5 you get rid of
all the BT clusters ot6 is just a
training course to teach you how to auto
ot7 well t7 is now more BTS except it's
in in the environment and stuff you're
trying to locate BTS you can find them
on your body but it's just more BTS
okay and then ot8 is remember we talked
about in all these auditing sessions
throughout the entire Scientology Bridge
you have people who've run hundreds or
thousands of past life whole track
incidents these memories have become
part of their self-identity of who they
even think they are
ot8 you go through all these past life
recalls and essentially I'm
oversimplifying this a little bit he
goes Psych all those past life memories
weren't yours
they were your BTS
and he goes now that you've discovered
this now you know who you are not
and you are ready to find out who you
really are
well now you're supposed to find out who
you really are on ot9 and 10. those
don't exist